why you
L and you
CH and you try to make full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so as we continue with part two of The
Infinity Gauntlet what we see is that
we're picking up with Doctor Strange
here and again what's taken place up to
this point is that the great
disappearance has taken place as it's
referred to in the comics that half the
population on the planet Earth as well
as the universe has simply just been
blinked out of existence and so what
we'll see for the most part is virtual
uh Panic we'll see a lot of superheroes
trying to deal with this trying to cope
with this element of what it is that's
taking place both on the planet Earth
and Beyond and what we see with Doctor
Strange here is that he's gone to
consult Dr Hank Pim Hank Pim has arrived
at uh Doctor Strange's mansion and the
goal here is to try to find some way to
restore the Silver Surfer back to health
but because of his alien physiology
because of the fact that he doesn't
require any kind of nourishment to
survive it's kind of a coin flip here in
terms of what they can do in order to uh
to restore him or perhaps it's simply
that he's just healing himself and what
we see is that Hank Pim says that he's
done the best he can up to this point
that given the alien physiology of the
Silver Surfer that he's done everything
he knows and that all they can do is
simply just wait but what he also says
is that he has to return to the West
Coast Avengers due to what's happened
with The Disappearance in order to
assist them as best he can and that
doctor strange may also want to go on to
contact the original Avengers and let
them know what's going on here but what
we see is that as Hank pen begins to
leave Dr uh Doctor Strange seems to be
stuck in place he seems to be kind of
Frozen in place and one of his servants
attempts to shake him out of it but
Doctor Strange appears to be falling
into a trance and what we see is that
his spirit is more or less torn away
from his body that it is taken to a
place that seems to exists beyond the
Physical Realm perhaps uh in some sort
of Soul um maybe Middle Ground or
something like that but what we see is
that some unnamed individual some sort
of uh energy force has drawn Doctor
Strange's Essence to him and what he
tells Doctor Strange when he asks what
it is that he's doing here who this
individual is is that he's here to uh
help save this reality from the insanity
of Thanos but that he can't do it by
himself Doctor Strange replies by saying
that if this individual wants him to
gather up all these superheroes and all
these righteous individuals for a
conflict then he needs to do something
to demonstrate who he is because these
individuals most likely will not simply
just uh unite under the single banner of
a person that they know nothing about
and what we see this person saying is
that he can open his soul he can is
expose his soul directly to the soul of
doctor strange but the issue here is
that because both of their souls will be
exposed to one another that there is an
inherent danger here that one of them
could be destroyed or that they could
meld into a single person Doctor Strange
says this is a risk that he wouldn't
normally take but because of the Grave
nature of the circumstances that he will
do whatever he needs to get any kind of
help he can and so what we see is that
both of these uh individual souls are
sort of combined into water at the very
least they're able to look into each
other's souls and when Doctor Strange
looks into the soul of this unnamed
individual he develops complete and
total trust he now believes him and uh
and trusts in him implicitly and says
that he will do anything he need needs
to in order to uh assist this individual
in any way that he can from here we
switch to uh Dr Doom and what we see is
that Dr Doom is using his uh various
technology and instrumentation at his
disposal to trace the origin to trace
the location of the uh disappearance and
he traces the energies that caused the
grace disappearance onto the other side
of the uh of the Galaxy on the far side
of the Milky Way galaxy and so the
information that he has here is that one
he knows where it is but that too he's
also recognizing some kind of phenomena
that seems to be very similar to the
energies that caused the elimination of
half the life in the universe and that
this phenomena is uh is emanating from
the residence of doctor strange and so
what we see Dr Doom saying here is that
this is his Universe this is these are
his people on the planet Earth and that
no one has the right to uh go in and to
effectively uh begin wreaking havoc
without either uh speaking with him
directly or somehow asking for his
Assistance or involving him in some
Manner and so we see Dr Doom undertaking
the task of finding out what it is that
has gone on here but Dr Doom again also
has his own motives here because he sees
this as a chance to expand his own power
given the great power that was used for
this this this vast disappearance and to
also expand his scientific knowledge and
so this for the most part is the biggest
reason why he's here and we'll see that
play out when we get to the actual
conflict on the shrine of death out in
face later on in the Infinity Gauntlet
story from here we transition to draxx
the Destroyer OS and Fire Lord Lord on
Titan and what we know here is that
Mentor who was the father of uh of os
and and Thanos is one of the individuals
who has vanished from the universe and
what we see is that Isaac again the um
the autonomous computer system within
the uh The Fortress of uh Titan so to
speak uh is informing OS and Fire Lord
and dra Destroyer that this is all a
universal act that this is all taking
place across the universe that it's not
simply confined to Titan it's not simply
confined to the Milky Way galaxy that
all life in the universe has simply
vanished we then see that OS simply just
disappears but what we know here is that
OS is not one of the individuals who has
simply vanished due to the uh great
Vanishing because this has already taken
place what we see is that OS has been
taken by Thanos Thanos presumably using
the space gym has transported OS to his
location and Os realizes that Thanos is
in possession of the power gems now what
OS tells us here is that he's uh
familiar with the infinity gems he's
familiar with what it is that they can
do now how familiar he is with them is
something that Marvel doesn't explain he
simply just tells us that he knows what
they are and he recognizes that with all
of them on a single Gauntlet with all of
them being wielded by one individual
that this individual possesses a a power
that is virtually unrivaled within the
main Earth 616 Marvel Universe and so
what we see is that uh OS begins to look
around and he recognizes Mesto but he
also recognizes mistress death he
recognizes nebula who's simply just
walking around as a corpse who is
walking this fine line between life and
death Thanos says that this is a family
reunion that uh he has restored nebula
or that he's brought nebula to him more
or less poking fun at the fact that she
had presented herself as a granddaughter
to him falsely and he also says that his
mate that his lover here presumably
playing the role of his wife is mistress
death and that Mesto is simply here as
an adviser OS asks why Mentor isn't here
and Thanos replies that Mentor wasn't
invited nor will he be and he says that
he intentionally ensured that Eros I'm
sorry that Mentor was one of the
individuals who was eliminated during
the Great Vanishing that he made sure
that he was one of the people who was
simply just blinked out of existence and
the reason why is because Mentor would
attempt to find a way to take The
Infinity Gauntlet from Thanos he would
try to find some way to bring this
Conquest to an end and would be one of
the few individuals within the Marvel
universe that would probably be able to
do it not in the sense of sheer raw
power but in the sense that he would be
able to organize forces in such a way
that he would be able to achieve this
act but what Thanos says is that
ultimate power is now his that he can
reshape the universe with it and that
nothing can interfere with this Mission
what we see OS doing here is playing on
this OS says that if this is what Thanos
wants then nothing will interfere that
he will do everything he can to help
Thanos as best he can but what we see
Thanos realizing here is that OS is
using his powers to manipulate uh
emotions on Thanos and so Thanos simply
says how how poignant how powerful and
Charming can OS be when he can't talk
and so he takes os's mouth away from
here we see Thanos saying that this this
is how all things shall be from this
point forward anything that irritates
Thanos will simply just cease to be at
this point we switch back to Captain
America and what we get here is more or
less a list not a full list but a pretty
significant list of which superheroes
have gone missing as a result of the
great Vanishing and this is a pretty
important list and the reason why is
because throughout this conflict a lot
of you guys will ask questions like
where is Hercules where is Archangel
where is um The Invisible Woman the
fantastic for where's night Thrasher or
The Vindicator from alphal flight you
guys will ask a lot of these different
questions on where these superheroes are
and so what Marvel has done is they've
laid out uh some of the more uh
significant members of the X-Men the The
Avengers um Alpha flight and various
other superhero teams that were
relatively popular at the time this
story was written and simply said
they're just not here anymore they've
simply just been among the individuals
who have been blinked out of existence
and so what we see here is that Captain
America She-Hulk and uh the man standing
in the place of Thor Eric Masterson
analyzing all this information now this
idea of Eric Masterson is something that
I would like you to keep in the back of
your head because this again is not the
real Thor now the the story in terms of
how it is that Eric masteron begins to
undertake the role of Thor and how he
takes takes over this role of for a
pretty good amount of time is a very
very good story and so I'd like to do
that Justice and we'll talk about that
when we actually get into our discussion
of Thor after we finish various
characters when Infinity Gauntlet is
over but for the most part all we need
to do is simply just be aware of the
fact that this is not Thor Odin son this
is simply just Eric Masterson and what
we see is that all these individuals are
focusing on the fact that things are for
the most part very very bad that uh Eric
Masterson is trying to undertake the
role of Thor trying to speak like Thor
trying to ensure that he's ped off as
Thor but that everybody else is trying
to deal with the fact that some of the
most prominent superheroes in the Marvel
community commun are just gone at this
point we switch to Odin and what we see
is that Odin is an Asgard and he's
wearing the uh the ceremonial eye patch
of Sorrow now this is something that a
lot of people get confused in the uh the
movie of Thor we saw that um that
Anthony Hopkins was wearing an eye patch
the eye patch is worn as a ceremonial
thing it's not something that Odin
actually has to wear he hasn't actually
lost an eye and for the most part what
we see here is that Odin has called
together the Sky fathers now the sky
fathers are what we would consider to be
the old gods these are people like Zeus
Osiris of Egypt these are what what we
would look at to say that uh older parts
of society older parts of the world
generations and thousands of years ago
these were the people these were the
gods that ancient Humanity worshiped but
in the Marvel Universe these are actual
beings these are true beings they may
have been forgotten over the years they
may no longer be worshiped by people
over the years but it doesn't take away
from the fact that they are real and
they have a vast amount of of power and
as these individuals form under the name
of the sky father they have of the sky
fathers they have a significant amount
of power and what Odin does here is Odin
calls them together bands them together
and says that because of this great
power because of this great threat that
they need to fight together in order to
try to defeat Thanos but for the most
part this would be a laughable conquest
at best because the sky fathers despite
their vast power have absolutely no
ability to th the power of Thanos at all
in any way from here we transitioned the
windel Von to quazar and all we see with
this uh bit of the story is that quazar
has simply arrived to a uh predestined
or a pre- um arranged set of coordinates
by Epoch and what he simply says here is
that he's just supposed to wait that
quazar is simply just supposed to hold
out here that he's not supposed to do
anything until he's instructed to from
here we switch back to the story of
Ralph who has now undertaken the role of
pip the troll and for the most part pip
the troll is just the sidekick of Adam
Warlock and so all this really does is
confirm that Adam Warlock is now
becoming he's now rejoining the uh the
physical Marvel Universe and what we see
pip the troll here doing is simply just
waiting for Adam Warlock to wake up to
come out of his cocoon and as he's
waiting there's some kind of an
explosion in the Next Room that throws
him out of his seated position and into
the TV or simply just uh to a different
part of the room and when the explosion
ends he gets up and he goes into the
next room and asks this individual since
they can't stay here anymore where it is
that they're supposed to go and this
individual replies by saying after
Thanos from here we switch back to Dr
Doom at the residence of doctor strange
and what we see is that the Silver
Surfer has now woken up he's now come
too and Dr Doom has his doombots
restraining doctor strange and what we
see is dror strange pleading with Dr
Doom saying that he is Mally endangered
that he doesn't really understand he
doesn't really know what's going on here
but what we see is that the Silver
Surfer tries to uh to stop Dr Doom he
tries to overpower Dr Doom but Dr Doom
uses his power to overpower the Silver
Surfer now under normal circumstances
this would not happen Dr Doom would not
be able to overpower the Silver Surfer
despite his vast power but the Silver
Surfer is in a weakened position here
he's uh he's very very weak and so he
doesn't have his full physical strength
otherwise he would easily be able to
stop Dr Doom from here we see that Dr
Doom turns his uh power against doctor
strange and what he wants to know is
what's happened here he wants to know
everything that has taken place as far
as this great disappearance and the
forces behind it now Doctor Strange
initially doesn't say anything Doctor
Strange initially doesn't speak but what
we see is that before Doctor Strange can
say anything there's an explosion behind
them and we see that Dr Doom the Silver
Surfer and Doctor Strange all look
around at this point we see Adam Warlock
has arrived and Adam Warlock simply just
replies by saying that in his time he
was called Adam Warlock and that they
may also do so if they feel inclined
from here we switch back to Thanos and
what we see is that Thanos is using the
power of The Infinity Gauntlet to more
or less either psychologically or
possibly even physically torture OS and
nebula and again he's doing this as a
way to uh satisfy to please mistress
death but mistress death doesn't really
seem to find this the the slightest bit
interesting she doesn't find it at all
satisfying it's simply just uh something
she pays no attention to or doesn't
really give any kind of uh of credence
to from here we see OS um after the
torture is ended looking at Thanos and
coming to this realization that The
Infinity Gauntlet has driven Thanos
insane that this power has driven him
out of his mind and that on a whim due
to his sanity he could simply just
eliminate the universe and so this is
when when OS really grasps what it is
that's going on here and grasp the
danger of the situation from here we
transition back to Adam Warlock and
Doctor Strange uh Dr Doom and the Silver
Surfer and what we see Adam Warlock
saying is more or less explaining how it
was that Thanos was able to gain The
Infinity Gauntlet how it was that he was
able to uh to gain this fast power and
that he's arrived here in order to help
bring an end to these schemes Doctor
Strange realizes that Adam Warlock was
the one that communicated with him
earlier when he came to this
understanding of what it meant to
undertake the role of uniting all of
these superheroes We also see Dr Doom
commenting and saying that this is a set
of circumstances whose Peril whose
danger uh almost Rivals that of the
coming of the beyonder now Dr Doom says
that it does rival the coming of the
beyonder but there's a vast difference
here the beyonder had power that dwarf
anything that The Infinity Gauntlet
could do he was from an entirely
different Universe entirely different
Multiverse and he had incredible power
and could do pretty much anything that
he wanted to but we'll talk more about
him again when we get into the secret
Wars uh 1 and two and the beyonder but
what we see is that Adam Warlock says
that this is going to be difficult this
is going to be a fight that will uh very
well cost the lives of some individuals
and will require 100% of everybody
because it's going to uh they're
basically going to be going going
against forces that are going to require
cunning and guile to defeat as opposed
to Simply sheer power from here we see
that um Dr Doom challenges Adam Warlock
and asks him by what right it is that he
claims the mantle of leadership Adam
Warlock replies here by saying that he
is the one who battled Thanos previously
that he's the one that knows the secrets
of the inner workings of the infinity
gems and so with that knowledge he's the
only one that's really equipped to
combat Thanos he's really the only one
capable of going against Thanos and
successfully being able to organize
forces in an effective way to where
Thanos can be
defeated at this point we see Dr Doom
more or less counting his losses and
just kind of accepting this and sort of
moving forward but what we'll see is
that again this is not necessarily
acquiescence by Dr Doom so much as it is
Dr Doom just biting his time what we
also see is the Silver Surfer commenting
on whether or not Adam Warlock is truly
the person that should lead them that is
Adam Warlock really the best choice here
that Adam Warlock seems vastly different
from the Adam Warlock that he had met in
the soul world and so because no one
really knows anything about him no one
really knows anything about his
motivations other than what he claims
his motivations to be from here we
transition back to Thanos and again we
see Thanos manipulating reality to
torture OS and nebula and again he's
becoming extremely angry here he's
becoming extremely frustrated because
mistress death will not acknowledge Him
mistress death will not return his
affections and we see him yelling at her
we see him screaming at her asking what
it is that it would take to please her
that he's done everything that she's
asked he's given her the entire universe
that he would do anything in order to
make her uh love him that all he asks
here is that she simply just use her
voice and speak his name aloud and that
would be enough and so what we see is
that Thanos in his anger lets off an
energy blast he lets off this uh massive
force of energy in all directions and
what we see is that the first thing that
encounters or that is encountered by
this energy blast is a 20 million year
old red giant and what this red giant
does is simply just destroy it simply
just explodes and that's the end of it
from here we see some kind of spaceship
traveling through the uh through the
cosmos and the planet that the spaceship
is approaching is destroyed and we see
an individual here telling us that the
wrath of Thanos the Supreme Being is uh
is something to behold that this planet
is the second planet to be destroyed as
this being was traveling to it that is
the second banquet that has been robbed
from him and what we see is that this
person is galatis and Galactus is again
attempting to satiate his hunger but
also recognizes that the vast power that
Thanos has here is something that cannot
be ignored that is that is going to
require that Galactus go through the
process of bringing together a multitude
of forces in terms of the cosmic
entities in order to attempt to bring an
end to the power that Thanos has here
and that the issue here is that the
emanations that are being released here
that the power that is being displayed
here by Thanos will reach the planet
Earth and that it will only contain
about 2% of its power but it will be a
massive amount of energy nonetheless and
so what we see is that we transition to
the planet Earth and we see that cloak
who is one half of the team Cloak and
Dagger is by himself that dagger is gone
she is one of the individuals who is
simply been blinked out of existence and
that cloak feels as though because his
other half is gone that while they were
linked while they were kind of like two
halves as a whole as he describes it
that he doesn't really feel like he has
a reason to go on but what we see is
that he finds this reason to continue as
this force that was emitted by Thanos
reaches the planet Earth and Shakes the
entire planet humbling several cities
and and wiping out the Japanese islands
and of course we see that cloak uses his
ability to um to save various uh humans
to save them from their impending deaths
of falling off buildings or else being
crushed by rubble from this point we
transition back to Doctor Strange Silver
Surfer Dr
Doom and um Adam Warlock and what we see
here is that these individuals are
trying to deal with the aftermath of
this they're trying to understand the
aftermath math of what's G on here that
the power that Thanos has demonstrated
despite being on the other side of the
Galaxy is a power that most of them
couldn't really even fathom and that it
will take an incredible organization an
incredible upheaval for all of them to
be able to go sex successfully go
toe-to-toe with Thanos and so what we
see as a comment here we see the
question being asked what was that what
was that energy blast from here we're
going to bring an end to this video and
in the next video we're going to pick up
with battle formations preparations for
war and we'll see that uh we're more or
less seeing superheroes being organized
we're seeing superheroes being brought
together by Adam Warlock as they uh
begin the preparations for taking on
Thanos with that being said I will catch
you guys in the next video
[Music]
peace
oh